[Musique]
quand une entreprise marche bien
quand les clients sont satisfaits qu'ils
achètent les produits qu'elle fait des
bénéfices que les salariés soient
augmentés que les actionnaires touchent
leur part belle à la normale à ça
quand une entreprise de la malle alors
là il ya un problème les salariés ils
ont quand même fait leur travail mais
les actionnaires ils ont pris le risque
ça a mal marché c'est tant pis pour eux
ça c'est le risque de l'actionnaire et
c'est absolument pas normal qu'il puisse
y avoir des dividendes importants dans
des situations laquelle entreprise ne va
pas mais ce n'est pas seulement votre
question autre question c'était aussi
des salaires énormes la somme de
dirigeants moi je vous le dit tout de go
je trouve ça scandaleux je trouve ça
scandaleux pourquoi parce que il ya un
problème un peu morale à l'arrivée quand
même sur la valeur du travail de chacun
moi je veux bien et c'est normal que les
gens qui sont plus qualifiés qui
prennent plus de risques soit plus
rémunérés il n'y a pas de je trouve pas
que ce soit ce qu'on a eu de ce point de
vue là et d'ailleurs c'est vrai dans
tous les autres domaines les sportifs
qui courent plus vite que les autres ont
plus de mérite qu'on puisse travailler
campus suez à l'entraînement eh bien ils
sont plus récompensé le jour de foot
pareil les acteurs qui sont meilleurs
que les autres c'est vrai dans
l'ensemble de la vie il ya des limites à
sa et des limites à sa limite au mérite
draoui sais pas s'il ya des limites
aurait en tout cas y est les limites à
la différence aux inégalités de
rémunérations qui découlent de
différence mais parce que les différends
au mérite aussi faut voir pour porter
plus haut si c'est pas simplement votre
mail personnel c'est parce que j'avais
eu la chance de vivre de naître dans une
famille dans laquelle vous avez pu faire
des études l'autre a pas eu la même
chance j'ai peut être aussi mal à vous
aussi travailleur il est né j'ai été
longtemps vous savez le député de
sarcelles à sarcelles il y avait des
gamins qui était aussi malin aussi
travailleur que ce qu'il est c'est à
neuilly malheureusement leur vie était
pas la gêner et donc et donc il ya un
moment où il faut dire ça suffit il ya
un moment où en effet par la fiscalité
ou quelle que soit la méthode qu'on
emploie eh bien on attaque frau de front
des trop grandes inégalités de revenus
bernard guetta fiaf oui avoue à vous
entendre deux questions à vous entendre
on nage sentiment on a le sentiment
d'abord que ce sera en premier temps
dans un premier temps la relance et dans
un deuxième temps la régulation ça veut
dire quoi qu au sommet qu'au sommet du
g20 le 2 avril
on va oublier de fermer les paradis
fiscaux
on va oublier d'imposer les règles dans
ses appuis attendus et puis une deuxième
question vous connaissez bien l'europe
ancien ministre des finances tristesse
que vous croyez qu'il y a enfin un
espoir en europe de voir s'affirmer une
politique économique ou pas du tout
alors sur la première question non là
vous retournez dans l'autre sens à
l'autre extrême le balancier vous c'est
ce que vous disiez alors je me précise
pour être bien compris moi j'avais
tendance à penser je trouve que là le
balancier par trop de la régulation pour
l'avenir et pas assez de la crise
aujourd'hui donc je sais de redresser
vous venu tabac du coup vous parlait
plus que de la crise aujourd'hui et puis
vous risquez d'oublier non les paris
fils les deux les deux doivent se faire
il faut travailler s'ils se feront sauf
que les paras du losc hausse a été
observée au 16 avril après moi je suis
pour qu'on mène une action à la dynamite
contre les paradis fiscaux
tout le monde n'est pas de cet avis et
qui n'est pas acquis les projets set ça
a été retrouvée ainsi que reporter qui
convient son d'état qui considérait les
désordres des voix là pour faire la
négociation mais est un ensemble d'états
qui considère que c'est pas le plus
urgent des états unis s'est jamais été
la politique des états unis encore que
les états unis finalement sur ce qu'ils
appellent le blanchiment de l'argent et
notamment l'argent sale sont volontiers
assez assez sévères simplement je trouve
qu'on a attaqué ce problème avec des
instruments des armes trop légère et
qu'il faut sans doute aller plus loin
mais encore une fois je dis pas du tout
que il faut abandonner sa au contraire
je dis simplement qu'il faut pas que au
nom de s'intéresser à cela au nom du
fait qu'on veut faire de la meilleure
régulation on s'occupe pas du malheur
des populations aujourd'hui qu'il faut
pas se réfugier dans l'avenir pour but
aujourd'hui à vous on lit tu arrives et
du coup si on parle que d'aujourd'hui on
va oublier l'avenir non il faut faire
les deux il faut absolument avancer sur
les 2 et ma conclusion sur ce plan c'est
que aux réunions du g20 qui vont se
tenir dans les semaines qui viennent
sheila de haut niveau des ministres une
au niveau des chefs d'état les deux
plans doivent avancer les deux direction
la régulation l'organisation de
l'économie mondiale d'une part mais la
sortie de crise aussi doit avancer du
même pas
[Musique]